i'm just gonna say words and you just
say whether it's funny or not funny in
by itself okay
ready
peanuts
okay how about treadmills
not at all berries
gerbils
definitely funny gerbils are funny which
is gear
i'm sorry i can't help it
how about band-aids i love them when i
was a kid i used to put them on all the
time i loved them
i really did
and they were hilarious
pumpkins
i don't think so pumpkins are not funny
neutral pumpkins are neutral no jewel
oh the greatest of all time no no
t-o-a-t-s no ghosts goats are funny
honey have you seen my goat okay how
about milk is milk funny oh
milk is white
i think what we're gonna do right now is
now that you have your pen and paper
you're gonna write down three to five
things that you think about every day
tequila do you have a list of things
you're thinking about do i get up now
then i do i go to the diet app on my
phone
and the only other thing i can think
about is do i kill those roaches with a
sponge or my hand
so you are you
you are still working as a reporter yeah
and a photographer yeah i am it's
important to note that you are
i would say somewhat new york famous
no yes no yes in a very small circle a
very my dog walker said you know tequila
but she doesn't know me she just saw my
byline
that's fame
she you're famous
renowned but not quite famous
do you have a plans for the show
well you know gripes
you have grapes
it's my name tequila minsky
well life is a performance
but to be on this stage this is the
stage
i don't the performing doesn't bother me
it's like the material having good
material
my own good material that's what makes
me
extremely anxious barbara what are your
things you think about i have walk
morgan
study
monkey yo-yo on youtube i love him and
his family
eating food
and feeling only good
okay how about you nikki
every day
i watch
the colossal failure of our world
become more and more
irreparable
every day i wonder why ignorance rather
than its opposite
is on the increase
every day i lose all hope for mankind
wow every day
i wonder when the world as we know it
will end
thank you nikki thank you
[Laughter]
it's great
thank you well i love comedy it is a
true gift i think it's a it's like
taking medicine for your health what's
the end goal do you want to make
theater do you want to make comedy i
just want to learn i thrive on
edification i have to learn 100 new
things every day you mentioned
that comedy is a gift oh absolutely
again i know now now i know it sounds
strange because i don't believe in
really i would like to abolish all
religion from the world
and all gender from the i think gender
is such a
terrible concept and it creates so much
harm and you know i don't know this
human impulse to put us in boxes all the
time now not the nazis were famous for
that yes by the way i'm very very
obsessed with the holocaust
you can't believe that it actually
happened you think that you're going to
wake up from this nightmare that it
never happened germany hasn't learned
anything do you know what they're doing
in germany now i just i think the
question they're wiping out the 100
hundred-year-old thousand-year-old
villagers to to make way for coal mines
it's awful but i think the question was
if comedy is a gift oh yes it is yes
right
but i would like to uh be funny but not
in an artificial way you know genuinely
i think that you are genuinely funny you
do yeah
really yes you're the first person who's
ever told
you